pays autre situation sanitaire la russie
fasse un nouveau triste record de décès
quotidiens 1028 morts liés aux colis 19
ces dernières 24 heures du jamais vu
jusqu'ici vladimir poutine vient de
décréter une semaine chômé pour enrayer
l essor du coc u19 plus de précision
avec un autre correspondante maylis
déstresse
malice bonjour alors vladimir poutine
vient donc de s'exprimer après une
réunion avec les membres de son
gouvernement que faut-il retenir
bonjour face à l'aggravation de la
situation épidémiologique observée
depuis plusieurs semaines en russie
vladimir poutine vient d'annoncer qu'il
soutenait la proposition du gouvernement
russe d'instaurer une semaine chômé à
l'échelle du pays cette période pourra
être prolongé dans les régions de la
situation ne s'améliorait pas écoutez il
faut casser le pic des nouvelles infos
vague d'infection
et donc il ya des mesures de soutien qui
sont protégés qui sont proposés chers
collègues et je pense qu évidemment
les congés exceptionnels qui sont
proposés avec maintien du salaire
doivent être adoptées le chef d'état a
appelé les citoyens à rester chez eux
dans le cas où un membre de leur famille
contracterait le virus et les régions à
contrôler le confinement de ses citoyens
avec tact et respect vadimir poutine
regrette par ailleurs le taux de
vaccination insuffisant dans le pays
alors que ce dernier possède d'après lui
le meilleur vaccin au monde écoutez et
encore une fois je tiens à le dire rien
que de moyens
soit être malade semaine soit se faire
vacciner mais il vaut mieux se faire
vacciner
puisque les conséquences de cette
maladie sont lourdes on prenait cette
responsabilité
prenez toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour vous protéger pour protéger votre
santé vos proches ou
rappelons que la russie a enregistré ce
mercredi 1028 décès dus aux coronavirus
ces dernières 24 heures un nouveau
record depuis le début de la pandémie le
nombre de nouveaux cas s'élève quant à
lui à plus de 34000
merci beaucoup à vous m'élisez ce trait
en direct depuis fochi en russie